Film Courage: Tobey when you accepted the role of Bobby
Fischer in the movie PAWN SACRIFICE, how much
research did you do on him and watching
of his mannerisms and studying who he
was? Tobey Maguire, Actor/Producer: I did quite a bit I watched and
listened to anything I could get my
hands on and kept doing that you know
for a long time.
Firstly to learn about him in the
beginning as we were setting out to
figure out what the movie was I you know
read a bunch and watched as much as I
could find and then later as we
had we were going towards making the
movie then I would just I would just
listen to him constantly or you know
watch interviews every day. Film Courage: Did your
feelings or opinion about him change in
any way after playing him and and being
immersed in his whole world for however
long the film shoot was? Tobey: You know I it's an
interesting thing when you're when
you're playing a character or when I'm
when I'm playing a character because I'm
basically going through a process where
I'm not looking to be reductive at all
or to judge the person. I could I could
from a different point of view talk
about Bobby and talk about some of the
things he said and say they were awful
and destructive and I I I do believe
that but in terms of kind of where my
sympathy lies I have to go dig into this
without judgment and just try to
understand right I look at behavior and
I'm really just trying to understand
behavior not judge the behavior so I I
find Bobby Fischer fascinating and I
have might kind of I guess assessments
as as I apply them to how I'm portraying
him.
Film Courage: Did playing Bobby Fischer give you any
epiphanies about your own life? Tobey: I feel
like I'm always learning. I don't I can't
say epiphany like as in there was some
you know big moment that I I took away
some piece of knowledge or insight that
I had never had before or that made me
like take a radical shift in my life but
but I I certainly learned things through
the process.